[Musique]
le remplacer monsieur capelli cependant
quelques semaines je vous demanderai de
l'accueillir avec bienveillance et
gentillesse comme vous savez le faire
les élèves de la 3e et obtenait en
moyenne de l'académie ses camarades
qu'elle est juste que vous avez j'ai 40
ans mais du coup pourquoi est-ce que
vous êtes encore suppléant
je vous demanderais d'être
particulièrement attentifs à leur cas
on dira ce qu ils ont répondu à la
question lui quel métier voudriez vous
exercez manutentionnaire hôtesse de
caisse femme de chambre professeur
suppléant tiens c'est pour toi c'est
dans ta gueule
allô allô a déjà eu des problèmes
ils ont toujours été très proches très
solidaire
c'était à dos et touche je comprenne ça
[Musique]
c'est bien tester leurs limites
qu'est ce que vous préparez voulait
vraiment se passe quelque chose dans
votre vie pour combler un vide ses pieds
noirs arrivé
[Musique]
que vous faites voulait pas voir la
vérité en face on
il n'y a plus d'avenir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]